Alhamdulillah we
thank Allah for
his
infinite blessings. I've been reflecting on
this
for a few of the Khutbas that I have been givien.
And for me I think it is a
great place to start we think about the verse.
that if you were to enumerate the boundings and the blessings of Allah that you would
never be able to count them and we can think of many blessings but at times
I feel that we Overlook one of the greatest blessings which is this blessing of life
that he is in his infinite Mercy In His Infinite rahma in his irada in his
kudra in his will
has brought us from a state of non-existence into a state of existence foreign
has there not come a time among human beings when he was not even a thing
mentioned were you and I were not even a thing mentioned but from the will of
Allah he has brought us into a state of existence
I was listening to a lecture the other day
and
The
Scholar
she
said
that
statisticians had
created
an
algorithm in
which they
calculated what
was
the
statistical
percentage that a human being would be born in the time that they are born which
is right now
with the DNA that they are born with and she said that the calculation was 400
trillion to one that it's a 400 trillion to one chance that you are born in
the time that you are born in right now
and if you were to enumerate the bounties of your lord you would not be able
to enumerate them bringing us from a state of non-existence into a state of existence
how could it be that this is just some random chance that we are here
what I look at that is the miraculous nature of Allah's desire for each and every
single one of us to be here at this time then I thought to myself how
could they even calculate 400 trillion to one
because that means that they would have to have determined every single possibility that brought my
parents together
and brought their parents together and brought their parents together and the circumstances that prevented the
things for or them from meeting other people only Allah can determine this what I take
from it is that each and every single one of us is a miracle sitting here
right now
from the desire of Allah and we should not think of ourselves of anything other than
that
of that miraculous nature and then as I said from the mercy of Allah that we
are not running around in this world trying to figure out why we are here asking
that question
who is my Lord what is my purpose where am I going that he alhamdulillah by
blessing us with Islam
has given us a path to answer those questions has given us a messenger sallallahu alaihi
wasallam to show us in the human form that way to his pleasure Allah
and as we begin to think about things in this manner then perhaps we will see
ourselves and our relationship towards Allah in a different meaning
there is a lot to deal with right now we understand this and we know this
this pressure is both internally and externally with regard to Muslims
but the reality is the state in which we exist is left up to us what
we determine it to be is what it will be and what do I mean by
that what I mean by that is the incredible opportunity that each and every single one
of us is given by Allah as mentioned in a Hadith
as short perhaps as this Hadith may sound it is incredibly profound
ly abdb that regardless and irrespective of whatever the situation is outward whatever it seems like
is happening on the Manifest there is the reality of Allah and he says in that
Hadith that I am as my servant thinks I am I am as my servant thinks
I am the onus for happiness and joy is on us Allah has already created us
and guided us and given us Islam and given us Iman to act upon it and
then allowed us to make the choice of how we will feel
of how we will take in all of this ebb and flow that we have seen
historically happening time and time and time again yes these are difficult times but the ummah
has passed through difficult times
one million people I'm sorry it said that they were yes a million people killed in
a week when Baghdad was raised to the ground in a week that's without the type
of technology that exists today for how human lives are taken can you imagine that
so the ummah has been through Dark Times this nation has been through Dark Times
but the determinant is with us of how we will respond to that end of one
near Abdi be
that's incredibly liberating it's incredibly liberating and then the fight is all of those external factors
and shelter those external factors that will prevent us
from having the Allah talks about having the joy that Allah wants to
talk about mentioned come to
success come to success alhamdulillah we heed to that call coming here and we thank Allah
for that
we thank Allah for that I just want to share a few notes with you a
few thoughts of something that I was talking with one of the faculty members one of
the Abdullah Abdul Hamid
we are talking about the zikr the thicker that we read after the Salat
so there are many other car there are many forms of vicar that we read after
the Salat but one that is mentioned is that we read subhanallah 33 times and alhamdulillah
33 times and Allahu Akbar 34 times at the end of a Salat and we know
this and we do this but in my opinion he had an incredible insight into something
he said why did Allah teach the prophet saws to read them in this order
why the subhanallah first and what he shared with me in my opinion is something that
was profound and shelter Allah we will find meaning in it he said that the subhanallah
coming first is this idea that when we look out into the creation of Allah we
are absolutely in a state of astonishment
and we are below bewildered by it Allah when we look at these mountains or rivers
or whatever it is that we see in this world we look at it on one
level we say subhanallah we're bewildered by it
but then there's another level and that second level is
a
level of
appreciation alhamdulillah so
now I look at that same thing and I look at that River and I say
alhamdulillah for that River that is Flowing that is bringing the aquifer so that we can
have water so that it will have grass so that it will eat the cows will
eat the grass so that I can have it I understand this whole cycle now in
a different way so now when I look at that River and it went from subhanallah
from bewilderment an astonishment it now comes to appreciation and what does Allah say about appreciation
and when you show appreciation and gratitude to what I have given you then I will
increase you
may Allah allow us to be people that are not only enamored Masha Allah by his
creative abilities because some people get stuck just at that they're enamored by this world
but what we're saying is no continue go further go into a state of hand
and go into a state which he said the last and final state is what Allahu
Akbar complete celebration complete celebration so let's talk about very briefly each one of these points
here
subhanallah comes in verses of the Quran
says that the command to glorify Allah by saying subhanallah also implies declaring declaring him to
be above every fault and shortcoming and affirming the attributes of perfection to him
declaring him to be above any fault and venerating him
when you read the tafsir is Nazir it means that Allah is free from all faults
that's the glorification of Allah which we do not prescribe to anybody which we don't which
we do not prescribe to anybody and if you look at this the first time that
we see this subhanika that comes in the Quran is when the Malaika when the angels
are responding to Allah and the challenge that Allah puts out to them when he says
that he has given Adam the names of all things
we have given Adam the names of all things
and then he says to them
inform me I'm the only bit of smell like in control
tell me the names of these things tell me the names of these things if it
is true that you are informed of these things
in
the all-knowing and the wise the all-knowing and the wise and what did the Angels say
to Allah they say glory be to you we have no knowledge except for that which
you have taught us but the response their initial response is subhanak that's the point that
I want to make their initial response is subahanic and then again when do we find
it
those that glorify or make the victim of Allah standing up or on their sides or
lying down meaning that the scholar said if there is no other state that a person
can be in either you're standing up or you're reclining or you're lying down unless you're
able to levitate or something like that but that's another tafsir but these are the states
meaning that
in all of those States and what do they do thinking about contemplating about this world
contemplating about it thinking about it and using it as a means to increase them in
their Iman and what's the next thing that is said you have not created this ingest
you have not created this in play subahanik Subhan glory to you so again at this
state of bewilderment
that were just astonished by the creative Majesty of Allah
mashallah
and then
this Ayah moving now into the hand it's a longer eye and I'll read just the
last part of it
when it's talking about people of the inhabitants of Jannah alhamdul so hamd now is what
as we said hamd is the is the praise the showing gratitude to Allah
this hammed so first we have this bewilderment and then we have this appreciation if you
will
appreciation for all things that are given to us
who
has
guided us
to
this
meaning El
Islam and
we
will
not
be
guided if
he
did
not
guide us so showing appreciation not just for the things that we have that's a material
Level and perhaps you've heard me say this before the difference between a material of you
in the material world and the view in the spiritual world is like this a material
reality is a thing that I am this physical being that contains a soul so I
look at all things in a material plane
but the spiritual view is to look at the reality that I'm a soul which is
contained in this body
and now I will look at things spiritually and then the physical things are only secondary
but the soul is given the Primacy the soul is given the Primacy the spiritual reality
is given the Primacy
because it's not just about things let's look at this Dua beautiful Dua of the Prophet
all of the duas of the Prophet saws are beautiful but let's look at this one
in particular the Dua that he reads when he gets up for it when he gets
up for the night prayer
okay well read it in Arabic first and then I'll read the translation after
it says he
starts
off
Allah
praise
first thing he does when he's getting up and making this to us to Allah it's
all about praise
it's all about praise but it's not about praise for material things
it's orienting us to the that's what he sallallahu is constantly doing he's constantly orienting us
to the akhara over and over and over again when he gets up the first thing
he says oh Allah all praise us for you you are the possessor of the heavens
and the Earth and whatever is in them and all Praises for you are the possessor
of the heavens and the Earth and whatever is in them and all Praises for you
are the light of the heavens and the Earth and all that is in them all
Praises for you you are the king of the heavens and the Earth and all Praises
for you you are the truth
and you are the truth and your promise is truth the meeting with you is truth
the word is truth Paradise is truth hell is truth the prophets are truth and Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is truth I re surrender my will to you and I believe in
you that's the that's that hunt that's that appreciation that he has guided us to all
of this so when we sit after that Salat it is not just something as simple
as alhamdulillah or subhanallahu alhamdulillah let's look at them at a deeper level what is that
thing that I'm saying subhanaka for right now when I'm making this 33 times what are
33 things that I can think of right now in my life that I'm saying subahanica
for what are 33 things in my life that I'm saying alhamdulillah for what are those
things for that glass of water that has quenched my thirst all the way through this
home that I've got to the children that I have to the life that I have
to this degree that I have for the future that I have and for the fact
that you have put me in the um of Satan Muhammad in sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
to be that a quarter of the Prophet a quarter of the Quran is mentioned about
a quarter of the Quran is wrenching about Musa that he asks Allah when he sees
the reward of the ummah of saying Allah has brought you and I too alhamdulillah
he asks Allah to be a member of the ummah what did I do what did
I do to receive that honor that a prophet such as Musa Allah has spoken to
asks Allah to be in the ummah and Allah chose you
and
Allah
chose
you
alhamdulillah
foreign
oh
my God
in
alhamdulillah
Illinois
astonishment in
bewilderment
to the makama of appreciation we then find ourselves in the station of Celebration
when does this Akbar something that we are ordered to do when does it happen
happens at the read it happens it doesn't happen in this we have the takibirats of
the read why do we have the attack birat of the read because it is a
celebration for something that we could only dream of a celebration that after the Arafat after
her judge have left out of that Allah never will turn away the Dua of the
supplicator so all of the supplications that people have been asking for
all of the supplications that the people have been asking for all the desires that they
had to be forgiven of their sins that Allah has forgiven them so what is the
command there to do it's to celebrate how do we celebrate Allah Allah and the shame
of it the shame in our day and age is how this beautiful celebration is being
twisted and being used to take innocent lives
the beauty lies in the celebration of the riblaw of the pleasure of Allah and nothing
else
as much as people want to claim it it remains true to its essence
and again just a few or an ayat
the Ayah that we know about Ramadan foreign
this last part right here and
that Allah doesn't want to
make things difficult for
you
and
he
wants you to complete the number of days it's talking about the days that you would
have been fasting he doesn't want to make things difficult to you he wants you to
complete these days and that with that completion of the Ramadan that you magnify here or
you celebrate Allah by saying the tech beers for having been guided so that we can
be grateful to him that's that reality
that's that reality and then again connected with the Reed with the slaughter the sacrifice of
that lamb that happens what does Allah say Allah
again here in
closing it
is
neither their meat on
that sacrifice it
is
not this physical act of sacrificing but the act of taqwa that we would sacrifice our
wealth and our time in following in the way of our father Ibrahim and our prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that we will sacrifice for the sake of Allah but as he said it's not the
meat it's not the blood that reaches Allah it's the taqwa in our hearts and no
one can judge us on that and no one knows what it is no one knows
what that reality is it's a secret between the ABD and Allah it's a secret between
the servant and Allah we ask Allah
and what does he say here
and like that he has allowed these animals to be subjugated by you
so that you will glorify Allah so that you will celebrate Allah
for what he has guided you to for what he has guided you to
may Allah give us
the reality of
the celebration of
Allahu Akbar may Allah allow our astonishment and
bewilderment
of
him
be
turned
into
a
beautiful
means
of
appreciation
foreign